Greg's leftovers
oh geez I am very worried right now time
once again for leftovers it's the Emmy
winning cooking segment I stole from
Rachel Ray
I kid
it's where we read the jokes we didn't
use this week as with any leftovers you
never know if they're any good to dig in
and as always it's my first time reading
these and I mean that so here goes
President Biden sparked concerns about
his mental Fitness at a health event
Wednesday when he repeatedly called out
for deceased congresswoman Jackie
wolorski the White House clarified that
when he asked Jackie are you here he
meant Jackie Kennedy
foreign
[Applause]
a Florida TV reporter was criticized for
putting a condom on her microphone
during a hurricane broadcast she said it
kept the mic from getting damaged while
the mic complained it couldn't feel
anything at all
[Applause]
in a speech at the Korean demilitarized
zone Kamala Harris mistakenly referred
to America as having a long alliance
with North Korea the vice president
blamed her confusion on the location as
it's the first time she's ever been to a
border
boom how
in an appearance on Bill Marsh show
Michael Moore predicted a landslide in
November he wasn't talking about the
Democrats chances that's just what
happens when he gets out of bed
ooh families of victims if Jeffrey
Dahmer are complaining about the
Killer's new miniseries on Netflix could
have been worse it was originally
scheduled for the Food Network
what could they complain about
it New York City's residents are upset
over mayor Eric Adams plan for a migrant
Tent City on the bright side at least
Julie will have a place to pass out
after happy hour
funny because it's true
a widow in India lived with her
husband's corpse for 18 months saying
she was unaware he died
doctors validated her claim saying he
was responding at the level of most
married men
[Laughter]
happened
you try being married to women
why do you think they call it gay
lizzo had the honor of playing James
Madison's 200 year old Crystal flute
during her Washington DC concert an
already Dynamic artist she now also
she's now also the Pied Piper of pot
pies
Because I'm Happy it could have gone in
a bad Direction
according to a new study the average
person begins to worry about their
Vision at age 39 except for fela's wife
who said blindness can't come soon
enough
laughs
it's insulting the panelists tonight
Alec and Hilaria Baldwin announced they
had their seventh child this week once
again Alec found out the hard way he
wasn't shooting blanks
I saw that one coming three one though
yeah the Biden Administration has
proposed a new rule that would require
Airlines and travel sites to include all
fees in ticket prices this proposal is
opposed by every major legitimate
Airline and also Spirit Air
laughs
and finally a study out of New Mexico
found men with bigger penises are
perceived as more outgoing to which I'll
add hey how's it going my friend
good to see you what a great week it
shows thanks for joining us let's do it
again
[Applause]
I feel Batman yeah I know me too
how do you think I feel I had to say it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else